introduced in year 5 season 1 descent is
an AR training simulation at the NSA
facility it was designed to test the
limits of the Ortiz robotics Tech agents
are forced to leave their gear and shd
behind to help Wally extract Intel from
the NSA database
through this Intel we will discover a
wealth of knowledge about the history of
the simulation at Ortiz robotics
connection to the division Natalia
Sokolova and Kelvin McManus
[Music]
I'm going to run through these
recordings as they've been unlocked and
give a summary on what I think is going
on and what this could mean in our
current timeline
cow how's the family Felix got into
Medical School your pain of course of
course
well I know our pockets aren't as deep
as yours hopefully you'll play nice in
the bidding war today oh Cal I don't
want to start a war with you we're not
interested in a bidding war we've set
the price either you can pay it
or you can't
what Claire means to say is this
technology is not exclusive everything
you see today will be available for your
organization with top of the line
security to ensure that your data stays
secure remotely accessible and
permanently backed up on a private
apocalypse proof server at one of our
bases in North Dakota or Alaska
Alaska
isolated and cold easier and cheaper to
maintain security and temperature
control of the servers I assume you're
underground and using geothermal cooling
that's correct Ms Sokolova
Nat please
Ortiz robotics is showing a presentation
of what they are working on and those
invited include Kelvin McManus the
Secretary of Homeland Security for the
United States and Natalia Sokolova the
CEO of Circle of concern
the founders of Ortiz robotics Claire
and Alexander Ortiz are either husband
and wife or a perhaps family in some
other way like brother or sister
this interaction is obviously quite
early on as they mention her brother
Felix has just been accepted into
medical school and as we know this is
someone the division would take down
much later on
so it looks like Natalia and Kelvin have
been friends for quite some time or at
least have been running in the same
circles
otherwise nothing huge here but it
certainly sets the scene for the comms
that are about to play out
Kyle wants us to update all three
systems on his watch why someone said
the color cycling made him look like a
disco ball
was it Vic or Natalia
does it matter yes because if this is
about function or ego I have different
solutions function
he doesn't need help with his ego we can
have all three accessible through a
single interface but it could create
security issues a back door into the
systems that would make it much easier
to hack as long as you have legitimate
access to one of the systems you could
get into the other two is that a bug or
a feature depends on how clandestine and
classified you want your organization to
actually be in practice the watches are
a nerd until Isaac is activated right
more or less until you're activated and
we maintain activation it's just a watch
a very smart watch yeah but without
activation and the brick it's just a
watch that someday May alert you to get
off your ass and get to work
so until activation there really isn't a
threat not to security
but they are passive they are recording
everything all the time and filling the
databases if he wants his analysts to be
able to access all that Intel and data
then feeding all three into the same
repository could be beneficial
but it's definitely not secure
what about the other databases
right diamond yeah
yeah I mean sure it's all built on the
same Tech if he wanted a back door into
their operations to monitor them it's
just a matter of giving them access to
their database
why would that be the hook up
it's one server on One update five
minutes
but it would put our other contracts in
danger if they ever found out
how would they find out the same way
Kyle would find out they would all have
access to the same back door if they are
all from the same route it's just a
matter of finding the right file
it's all there but if someone gets bored
or goes looking they can find anything
they want
if they've got the skills and patience
to weed through the garbage first
so much to unwrap with this one firstly
the mention of Vic as in Vikram Malik
this is how long he's been working with
Natalya years I wonder what this has to
do with his dodgy interactions at odia
when we first found him
most of this interaction was talking
about the security flaws of linking
three systems together to be used as a
single interface this doesn't really
mean too much until The Mention Of
Watches come up they're talking about
Isaac
but what do they mean about three
systems the obvious one is Isaac and
then there's something they're calling
Diamond so what is the third one Anna
actually this doesn't make sense this
was years before the outbreak and wasn't
at Theo Parnell who made Anna well
actually going back it doesn't
specifically say that he made it and if
we take in that last line where clear
mentions that provided they have the
skills and patience to work through the
garbage first an individual would be
able to access all three databases
including Anna so perhaps this is what
Theo did
but this would mean he had access to
Diamond 2 which actually says a lot when
you realize who's using Diamond it even
makes me think that I need to reinstate
the quinoa's write hashtag I'll explain
why
Isaac and Anna we've obviously heard of
before but what is Diamond well this is
actually very easy to figure out Natalia
is involved in the situation so all you
need to do is take a look at the Black
Tusk units we've been staring at right
in the face since they first arrived in
DC
any division agents with extreme
prejudice
they're professionally trained
this Army was designed to eliminate
Washington's last line of defense
not only do the black tasks have their
own version of Isaac but Aaron Kina has
had access to the wealth of information
contained in all three of the databases
the working behind the scenes since the
beginning of the outbreak the black task
working with the Secretary of Homeland
Security the assassinations of the
presidents the bringing of Alice over to
their side and probably a lot more that
we don't know yet heena saw it all
but then Kino would also know from this
that Calvin has access to all three and
would have no problem hunting down his
Rogue agents that are using Anna this is
obviously how his Hunters are able to
track down agents so quickly too
another interesting point is that the
shd watches have been recording agents
since long before they were activated
those who could have had access to this
information could have swayed agents
away from their mission long before the
outbreak started
I really want to dive into the Swanson
more because it opens up a lot of
questions but before I get too carried
away let's see what the other comps have
I'd really like to see the new
prototypes when you have them ready
until then it's a pass for me that's too
bad Nat I really think you'd benefit
from getting in on this early be able to
shape the r d
she's right it's not a good fit besides
I'm not really comfortable working with
private organizations with practically
no public profile Beyond so-call of
concern I can't imagine your entire
business is built around tactical knee
pads a value discretion Mrs Ortiz and I
am sure you can appreciate that it's not
wise for a woman in this industry to lay
all her cards on the table until
she is ready to play them
I can if you're concerned about the data
we can build a private server with
biometric security only people you've
personally vetted would have clearance
to access or amend your services that's
excellent to know
Alexander please do get in touch for a
demonstration once you get the interface
down to a single component
excellent
well I'll let you finalize this deal
account to get the benefit later
wouldn't miss it for the world now Alex
tell me where do I sign
moving past the initial unveiling of
what Ortiz Robotics are working on
Natalia isn't yet sold on the idea and
would like to see more before signing
any contracts
she's concerned about the amount of data
these systems will be gathering in the
security protecting it which given the
last conversation between Claire and
Alexander this is a fair concern to have
however it's very obvious at this point
that clear does not trust Natalia at all
it goes in the simulation this could be
a game changer we're glad you agree does
not know about this no this is a
Fail-Safe for your agents only good
good there may come a time when you need
to cut off her access to the network and
until you can isolate your access this
is an insurance policy against a
potential coup you're a true patriot I
wouldn't say that I'm sure Nat would be
willing to pay top dollar for something
like this I'm sure she would but some
things are too dangerous to give to the
highest bidder some things should only
belong to the people
Kelvin has access to all data from all
three systems he now has access to
mobile shd servers something that
Natalia knows nothing about
firstly this shows that they really
aren't that close and that Kelvin would
like to have a little something he can
hold over just in case
but I wonder what she'll say if and when
she finds out
the mobile servers are the reason the
division agents were able to take back
the White House they've also been used
in the division Crossroad novels these
have been instrumental in allowing
division agents to continue using Isaac
and the tech regardless of whether the
signal is bad or in some cases the shd
network has been taken down
however Natalia has her own Tech Geeks
I'd be surprised if she didn't already
know what Kelvin is doing in the current
timeline and is just keeping it to
herself for now this is potentially
showing a lead up to a betrayal within
the enemy ranks which would certainly be
welcomed by the division
summing up what we have learned here a
company called Ortiz Robotics are the
ones responsible for the creation of not
just Isaac but two other similar AIS one
of them could be Anna and the other
something called Diamond which is
looking quite likely to be something
that the black tasks are using
both Kelvin McManus and Natalia Sokolova
have been given access to purchase this
technology Kelvin from Secretary of
Homeland Security point of view and
Natalia as a private contractor
the fact that Kelvin wanted all three
systems accessible through one interface
exposed a floor where anyone with access
to one of the three could access all of
the data provided that someone knew
where to look
so Claire and Alexander granted this
allowing him access to all three
databases but also anyone else with
access to potentially do the same thing
Claire Ortiz doesn't trust Natalya so
has been favoring Kelvin in the way
these systems have been designed
providing them with security measures if
there was ever falling out between them
columns have been awesome the second one
in particular opened up so much
I really need to sit down and think
about this some more so much time has
passed in game between these comms in
prison day I need to make sure I haven't
missed anything
interesting that the black task could
have their own version of Isaac but
while it's based on a similar system to
Isaac and Anna it's still a little
different
they don't have watches to start with so
they managed to consolidate it down to a
single brick type piece of equipment
makes me wonder though what are the
hunters using is it one of these three
systems or is there a fourth one and
given that we don't see anything on them
that would tell us which system it is
other than the Isaac and Anna watches
that they could be seen carrying as
trophies is this the reason they wear
masks
is that their brick slash watch for
whatever system they're using
so many questions but for now I think
I'll cut this video off let me know what
you think about these first four
distinct cons are you as excited as I am
for the rest of them
thanks again for watching and extremist
malice extreme media
[Music]
[Applause]